This expression is the odd one out. The other ones equal positive 1. This
expression equals 1 since we have the same expression in the numerator and the
denominator. We've seen something similar like this before if we just switch the
terms in the denominator we can see that numerator and the denominator have the
same factors. Notice that I'm not cancelling an individual term. I'm cancelling
an entire numerator with an entire denominator. So I have one divided by one or
just one. This one might have been a little bit tricky. Here we have a negative
one times our rational expression. Well we can just distribute this negative
sign or this negative one to each term and the numerator. This would give us x
plus 3 Divided by 3 plus x. This fraction is identical to this rational
expression, so we know it equals 1. For this rational expression, we know that
these factors can reduce to 1, but we're left with a negative sign out in front,
or a negative 1 times 1, which is just negative 1.